en este vídeo vamos a ver una reacción a
uno que es estéreo selectiva primero
vamos a ver todos los pasos de la
reacción y vamos a ver qué productos
podemos obtener con ella y después vamos
a ver por qué es estéreo selectiva aquí
a la izquierda tenemos nuestro alcohol
el carbono que está enlazado con el
grupo o h es nuestro carbono alfa y el
carbono de al lado es nuestro carbono
beta y tiene dos protones beta y sabemos
que en el mecanismo de reacciones e1
perdemos uno de los protones beta por
acá tenemos otro carbono que está
enlazado con el carbono alfa pero este
otro carbono no está enlazado con ningún
hidrógeno así es que eso lo tenemos que
preocuparnos porque pasa en la reacción
con el carbono de la derecha tenemos un
ácido muy fuerte ácido sulfúrico que
llega y protón a al grupo h entonces voy
a poner por aquí un hidrógeno con carga
positiva en lugar de escribir a toda la
molécula del ácido sulfúrico
un par de electrones libres del oxígeno
llegan y se llevan al hidrógeno del
ácido sulfúrico y esto es lo que nos
queda tenemos un anillo vencen y ccoo
por acá
pongámosle sus electrones y por acá
tenemos el grupo h que va a ser protón
ado y le estamos poniendo una cuña
porque sale hacia arriba de la molécula
ahora el oxígeno tiene dos hidrógenos el
oxígeno también tiene un par de
electrones libres pero tiene una carga
formal positiva pero veamos qué pasó con
los electrones este par de electrones
libres se llevó un protón del ácido
sulfúrico y ahora forman un enlace con
ese hidrógeno todavía no terminamos de
dibujar esta molécula porque este
carbono tiene un hidrógeno que lo
tenemos que dibujar así porque se está
alejando de nosotros alejando de la
pantalla y este carbono beta sabemos que
está enlazado con dos hidrógenos uno lo
vamos a poner en una cuña y el otro lo
vamos a poner con una línea de iones
ahora voy a dibujar por acá simplemente
ch3 el siguiente paso de nuestro
mecanismo de reacción en uno es que el
grupo saliente se vaya y aquí tenemos a
una molécula de agua como un grupo
saliente los electrones de este enlace
se quedan con el oxígeno y así perdemos
una molécula de agua y además este
carbono de acá el carbono alfa pierde un
enlace por lo que aquí estamos formando
un carbó catión pero antes de dibujarlo
necesitamos un poco más de espacio
así es que aquí tenemos a nuestro anillo
vencen y ccoo con sus electrones y
tenemos aquí la cadena de carbonos ahora
este es el carbó catión cuando el agua
se va llevándose los electrones del
enlace este carbono se queda sin un
enlace con una carga formal positiva
sabemos que las reacciones en uno
necesitan que el carbón sea muy estable
pero
este es un kart vocación bencílico
entonces si es muy estable y eso es
porque aquí podemos dibujar varias
estructuras de resonancia aunque eso lo
vamos a dibujar una para notar darnos
tanto vamos a sacar una copia podemos
por ejemplo tomar estos electrones y
pasarlos para acá y entonces se formaría
un enlace doble entre estos dos carbonos
antes teníamos una carga formal positiva
aquí pero acaba de recibir los
electrones de un enlace entonces ya no
tiene carga formal positiva este carbono
sin embargo le acabamos de quitar un
enlace a este carbono de acá que ahora
tiene una carga formal positiva pero
seguimos teniendo estos electrones en el
anillo vencen y ccoo que se comparten
entre todos los carbonos del anillo
vencen y ccoo y así tenemos otras
estructuras de resonancia y es una
molécula muy estable porque ahora
podemos mover estos electrones para acá
y ahora la carga positiva la tiene este
carbono pero
vamos a dibujar el único propósito de
esto es mostrarte que este es un kart
vocación bencílico muy estable
estabilizado a través de la resonancia
pero bueno ahora vamos a regresar a
donde estábamos vamos a seguir viendo
cuáles son los posibles productos de
esta reacción e1 ahora una cosa que
quiero que mantengas presente es la
posibilidad de rotación sobre este eje
sigma así es que vamos a dibujar por
aquí una de las formas que puede tomar
este carbó catión con esta molécula pero
bueno para hacer las cosas más sencillas
vamos a llamarle fenil a este grupo
vencen y co tenemos aquí al grupo fenil
luego tenemos aquí nuestro carbó catión
con una geometría plana este carbono
demorado ahorita es un kart vocación sp2
y british ado entonces tiene un orbital
p no híbrido
que estamos dibujando por acá y este
carbono tiene una carga formal positiva
este es nuestro carbó catión y luego por
acá tenemos otro carbono pero aquí hay
que recordar que en este enlace sigma
podemos tener rotaciones tenemos este
eje de rotación y aquí podemos tener
varias con formaciones pero voy a
empezar escogiendo una de ellas por aquí
voy a decir que uno de los hidrógenos su
enlace es paralelo al orbital p del
carbó catión luego tenemos otro
hidrógeno por acá y entonces nuestro
grupo metil tiene que estar por acá ch3
esta es una de las posibles con
formaciones y ahora para ver cómo
obtenemos el producto a partir de esta
conformación vamos a ver un vídeo
ahora para hacer las cosas más sencillas
en el vídeo que vamos a ver el grupo
metilo está representado con un color
rojo
el grupo fenil con un color morado y
finalmente este orbital p es de color
naranja aquí lo tenemos
este es nuestro carbó catión y le puse
estas cosas para que representen al
orbital p pero observa que la geometría
alrededor de éste carbó catión es plana
y este de acá es nuestro grupo fenil y
además sabemos que tenemos rotación
libre sobre este enlace entonces podemos
rotar esta molécula para obtener la
conformación que estábamos dibujando en
esta conformación estamos poniendo al
hidrógeno con su enlace paralelo al
orbital p y este enlace le puede donar
un poco de su densidad de electrones al
orbital p en el mecanismo de reacción e1
tomamos este hidrógeno y se lo quitamos
a la molécula y así podemos ver el al
que no que se forma
en la cee pero podemos ver que es un al
que no trans porque el grupo fenil está
en la esquina opuesta que el grupo
metilo pero como podemos girar sobre
este enlace hay otra conformación que
podemos tener
tenemos aquí este otro enlace entre
hidrógeno y carbono que puede estar
paralelo al orbital p así es que le
puede donar un poco de su densidad de
electrones al orbital p y el mecanismo
de reacción de eliminación y uno puede
llevarse este hidrógeno y así se forma
otra vez un doble enlace pero en esta
ocasión es un al que nos cis porque el
grupo fénix y el metilo están del mismo
lado del enlace doble
pero bueno regresamos a nuestros dibujos
como vimos en este vídeo alineamos el
orbital p del carbó catión con el enlace
que se va a romper en esta reacción es
uno entre el hidrógeno y el carbono aquí
el orbital p está alineado en este eje y
el enlace que se va a romper entre el
hidrógeno y el carbono es paralelo a ese
eje y entonces la densidad de electrones
de este enlace puede ser donada al
orbital p y además en un mecanismo de
reacción e1 sabemos que llega a una base
justo en este momento y se lleva este
protón y entonces los electrones de este
enlace pueden formar un doble enlace y
como vimos en el vídeo esta conformación
nos da un al que no trans que vamos a
volver a dibujar por acá tenemos aquí al
grupo phoenix
aquí está el doble enlace y por acá ch3
y este es nuestro producto trans pero si
tenemos por acá una conformación
diferente obtendríamos el producto cis
así es que vamos a dibujar por acá
la otra conformación por aquí tenemos el
grupo fenil luego tenemos nuestro carbó
catión con un hidrógeno y además éste
carbó catión tiene una geometría plana y
tiene a su orbital p y también tiene una
carga formal positiva y luego por acá en
este carbono en lugar de tener a este
hidrógeno vamos a poner al otro ok por
aquí tenemos el otro hidrógeno y aquí
también el enlace entre el hidrógeno y
el carbono es paralelo al orbital p del
carbó catión pero esta conformación es
después de que hicimos una rotación
sobre este enlace entonces este
hidrógeno es este de acá y este
hidrógeno se encuentra por acá
y tenemos el grupo metilo pero
nuevamente la densidad de electrones de
este enlace puede donarse al orbital p y
en el mecanismo de reacción
uno llega a una base y se lleva este
protón y cuando sucede eso los
electrones que estaban formando este
enlace se pasan para que formando un
enlace doble entre estos dos carbonos y
así es como se forma el producto si
tenemos nuestro doble enlace por acá
tenemos el grupo fenil y por acá
el grupo metilo y este es nuestro
producto cis pero bueno ya que
encontramos cuáles son los productos de
esta reacción ahora sí vamos a hablar
acerca de por qué es exterior selectiva
bueno pues aquí tenemos dos estéreo
isómeros tenemos un isómero trans
es el 95 por ciento de nuestro producto
y un producto cis que es únicamente el 5
por ciento de nuestro producto y podemos
explicar esta diferencia fijándonos en
sus conformación es por acá tenemos el
grupo fenil que es muy estorbos o en la
esquina opuesta a nuestro grupo metilo
que es un poquito estorboso estos dos
grupos estorbosos están relativamente
distanciados entre sí y eso disminuye el
impedimento estético y a diferencia esta
otra conformación de la derecha tiene
estos dos grupos voluminosos bastante
cerca entre sí y por eso es que no
obtenemos tantos de estos productos cis
así es que obtenemos más productos trans
porque hay menos impedimento estético y
por eso se estabiliza más esta
conformación ahora por esta diferencia
es por la que decimos que esta reacción
es estéreo selectiva porque tiene una
preferencia por un producto
por el estéreo y somero más estable que
es el producto trans